ينضم الينا من غزه الان اياد القرار
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا وسهلا بك اذا
ما اخذنا بالاعتبار هذا الهدوء الذي يسود
حاليا على الاقل هل يمكن القول اننا
اقتربنا ربما من هدوء باتفاق
اسعد الله اوقاتكم الاجواء الموجوده حاليا
سواء كانت بالميدان او ما يرد من القاهره
الاجواء الى حد ما ايجابيه باتجاه امكانيه
الذهاب الى هدوء لكن هناك محاوله ايضا
للضغط على اسرائيل للالتزام بعدم تنفيذ
عمليات اغتيال او بعض القضايا التي كانت
مثاره ومطروحه مثل اعاده او تسليم جثمان
الشهيد خضر عدنان
وقد يكون هناك جزء من التفاهم اسرائيل لا
تريد لا تستطيع او لا لم يسبق ان اعلنت
انها تلتزم بشروط معينه وهذا بالعاده هي
تفعل ذلك حتى لو قالت ذلك لا تلتزم بها
مثل عمليات الاغتيال او عمليات ترتبط
بالحصار قبل ذلك او فك الحصار وغيرها الان
الجهود المصريه بعد تقريبا اربعه ايام الى
حد ما بدات تنضج الامور بهذا الاتجاه بعد
المحاولات التي كانت لي امس وكان في هناك
توجه بهذا الجانب لولا قيام اسرائيل اليوم
باغتيال القياده في السياره السرايا القدس
اياد الحسني كانت الامور ستتجه ايجابا
اكثر
والهدوء الاجواء العامه الموجوده حاليا
خلال الساعات الاخيره اكثر هدوءا ورشقات
خفيفه على مناطق غلاف قطاع غزه وكان هناك
قبل ساعات استهدافات في اراضي
زراعيه في قطاع غزه هذا الانطباع بهذا
الاتجاه بتقدير انه هناك مصلحه نتنياهو
اولا بالذهاب الى هدوء وهذا له مبررات انه
اراد ان يصل الى مرحله تتفاخر بها انه
استطاع ان يغتال سته من عقاده سرايا القدس
ومن اعضاء المجلس
العسكري
لسرايا سرايا سرايا القدس بهذا الاتجاه
يكون حقق انجاز مهم ذهب وخرج لهاد لتنفيذ
هذه المهمه رغم وفي المقابل هو ايضا يريد
ان يواجه الانتقادات التي ستخرج خلال
الساعات القادمه وبدات اصوات تعلو خلال
ساعات المساء في الاوساط الاسرائيليه نحو
ان هل فعلا ما فعله نتنياهو كان كانت
اسرائيل بحاجه له وهل كان ملح وضروري جدا
وهناك تهديد حقيقي على اسرائيل للذهاب الى
هذه الجوله من القتال التي قصفت فيها
المقاومه تل ابيب وان ايضا استطاع نتنياهو
بطريقه ان يوحد الفصائل الفلسطينيه ويفعل
غرفه العمليات المشتركه وهناك كانت يمكن
ان نسميه وحده وطنيه فلسطينيه واضحه
للمقاومه في مواجهه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
هذه
يعني هي تريد ان تذهب بعد اذنك هذه الجوله
هي هي رقم 15 الجوله رقم 15 منذ 2005 كما
تذكر وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه الشرط قبل قليل الى
الشر قبل قليل الى ان الى ان اسرائيل قد
تكون او نتنياهو قد يكون التزم بمجموعه
اشياء ليس من مصلحه اسرائيل ان ان تشير
اليها الان ولكن الاشكال دائما ان اسرائيل
لا تلتزم حتى بما تعلنه رسميا وبمعاهدات
رسميه فما بالك بما يتفق حوله ضمنيا او
سريا هذا هذا لا
يشيء بشيء مريح بالنسبه للفلسطينيين
هذا استاذ محمد امر طبيعي للجميع بتقديري
يدرك تماما انه هذه طباع طباع اسرائيل في
التعامل مع الفلسطينيين ومع غيرهم
بالمناسبه في كثير من الاتفاقيات
والتعهدات والمعاهدات السابقه والحاليه
وتجارب وقفه النار كما تحدثت تتجاوز 15
مره منها بالمناسبه خلال خلال الشهر
والنصف الماضي هذه تعتبر الثالثه حينما
ردت المقاومه فيما يتعلق حينما
استشهد الاسير الخضر عدنان وكذلك هنا تم
الاعتداء على المسجد الاقصى واليوم نحن
نتحدث عن هذه الحاله لذلك الاجواء العامه
تذهب باتجاه انه هذا هو المتوفر قد يذهب
باتجاه انه الحكومه الاسرائيليه نحن نتحدث
بالمناسبه عن يوم الخميس القادم تكون
مسيره الاعلام والتي يتجهز لها الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ايضا لكن هذا يعتمد كيف ستكون
رده فعل الاحزاب الاسرائيليه والمجتمع
الاسرائيلي بعد انتهاء هذه الجوله في
التعامل مع الحكومه الاسرائيليه وخاصه انه
نتنياهو في جزء مهم كنت اودي الاشاره له
في توجهه لهذه
الهجوم وعمليه الاغتيال الغادره في
لقيادات السرايا ان يريد ان يرضي بنجافير
ويرضي اليمين المتطرف داخل حكومته ويقدم
شيء بين ايديهم يساهم في تعزيز ائتلافه
الحكومه هذا امر قد يكون بشكل او باخر
نتنياهو نجح في هذا الامر
وقد يذهب باتجاه محاوله ايضا امتصاص او
عدم الذهاب الى مواجهه خلال مسيره الاعلام
بحيث ان يضغط على هذه لكن اذا هذه الاحزاب
او ضمن الائتلاف الموجوده وجدت انها نجحت
في ابتزاز نتنياهو وذهب الى الحرب مع غزه
خلال الايه الاربعه ايام الماضيه يمكن ان
يتكرر ايضا في مسيره العوده عفوا مسيرات
اقتحام المسجد الاقصى ومسيره الاعلام
والتهاب مجددا الى مواجهه جديده
وبتقدير انه الفلسطينيه لن تسمح بان تكون
هناك مسيره للاعلام يتم فيها اعتداء على
الفلسطينيين في القدس او اقتحام المسجد
الاقصى كما يخطط له هذا السياق اللي يرتبط
بالجانب الاسرائيلي وجانب الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في ملفات في الجانب الفلسطيني
يجب ان ندرك ايضا ان هناك تمارس اسرائيل
بخلاف هذه الاغتيالات ان هناك حصار منذ
اربعه ايام واغلاق للمعابر على قطاع غزه
الاوضاع الموجوده حاليا وان كان هناك
التفاف شعبي حول رد المقاومه على ما قام
به الاحتلال الاسرائيلي باعتبار ان
اسرائيل هي من بادرت لهذا الهجوم وانه
هناك كثير من القضايا مرتبطه بالوضع العام
في في قطاع غزه والفصائل الفلسطينيه
باعتقادها هي ايضا لا زالت عينها على
الضفه الغربيه هي تريد ان تبقي الحاله
الثوريه موجوده في الضفه الغربيه ولا تريد
ان تعود الاوضاع للمواجهه في قطاع غزه فقط
ويتم التسليط عليها
ونسيان ان الحاله الثوريه الموجوده بالضفه
الغربيه والعمل المقاومه بالضفه الغربيه
هو اكثر تاثيرا على اسرائيل في حالات
كثيره رغم القوه التي بنتها المقاومه في
غزه لكن الحاله الثوريه في الضفه الغربيه
هي اكثر ايلاما لاسرائيل
وتعزز هذا الدور وبالمناسبه احد اتهامات
اسرائيل لقطاع غزه وعوامل وعناصر الدافعه
لتنفيذ عمليه الاغتيال وفق الاجهزه
الامنيه الاسرائيليه هي محاوله فصل العمل
المقاوم في قطاع غزه عن الضفه الغربيه كما
تم من اغتيال الشهيد طارق عز الدين
الدستور الضفه الغربيه في سرايا القدس
وكذلك كثير من الاجراءات ضد الفصائل
الفلسطينيه لمحاوله منعها من تصوير الضفه
الغربيه شكرا لك اياد القرار الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي من غزه